july is national carpet cleaning month
and it's the perfect reminder to get
that carpet cleaned but not all carpet
cleaners are equal i am joined by ben
mckee general manager of zerorez las
vegas the sponsors of this segment to
tell us more
not all carpet cleaners are equal you
guys are far superior and it's because
of the water tell us about your zero
water that's right so we clean without
any soaps or harsh chemicals and what
that means mercedes is as a homeowner
you're not gonna have crunchy carpets
you're not gonna have weird chemical
deodorizers that are toxic put in your
floors you're going to have fresh clean
carpets like it came from the factory i
love when you guys come to our house
because not only do you have the fresh
clean carpets but i don't have to wait
three days for the carpet to dry why is
that you know our technology we have the
best equipment
in the realm of carpet cleaning our our
vacuum cleaner is basically a 300
horsepower vacuum it's hooked up to the
actual engine for the vehicle
and which is really rare in the carpet
cleaning industry coupled with you know
proper cleaning technique proper
training with our team we're able to get
these amazing results that you see
and the results speak for themselves
actually doug's going to show us here in
a second but i want to talk about that
amazing team that you talked about you
guys won best of las vegas i see the
difference when your team comes into my
home and how respectful they are tell us
a little bit about why you guys are the
best of las vegas well you know like
it's me doug and kevin we're all
brothers here running zero res and we
have families we we know what it's like
to invite a service person into our home
and so we just train our team on you
know the proper way to do it have
etiquette have empathy
and you know we're really there to serve
and make you a raving fan of zero res in
our process well we are and let's let's
see xerorez again in action here doug
you're the pro at this the master
first of all i don't know how you guys
managed to make let's hold on one second
while we get a shot of this carpet there
we go okay
you made the carpet so dirty i don't
know how you do that but then with one
swipe
boom look at that's one swipe one spot
and like you said it's an amazing time
of year to get your carpets clean you
know it's hot outside and we're getting
amazing dry times you brought that up
right now you get your carpets dry in as
little as like four to five hours after
we're done cleaning which is amazing you
can get your carpets clean in the
morning have a party in the afternoon
you're good to go it really is the truth
i love that about you guys and what i
also love is that you always offer
our viewers great specials you guys have
a great special going on right now we do
i've
it's crazy that we're doing this special
but you can get two rooms of carpet
clean for only 89 right now it's it's
amazing take advantage of the deal
that's probably the best deal i've ever
heard that you guys have offered that's
incredible and this goes for just your
average wear and tear your guests that
have come in your pets that have
destroyed your carpet absolutely we have
an arsenal of products that safely and
effectively address not only the odor
issues but also the stains that are left
behind by a fur baby and don't forget if
you're a business you need to clean up
your your your business you guys
specialize in that too we do and you got
to understand your customers even your
employees
first impressions count yep i know
people are trying to hire right now if
you've got a dirty office that you're
bringing interviewees into
get it cleaned up calls you a res we can
help you with every aspect of your
business yes thank you zerorez for
sponsoring this segment you guys are the
best don't forget take advantage of
their national carpet cleaning special
like he said two rooms of carpet cleaned
for only eighty nine dollars plus you
can save 20 percent on all pet
treatments call 702
840-3333 or go online to xerorez las
vegas dot com for more minimums apply
jillian we're going to send it over to
you